[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute machen wir ein leckeres rezept und
zwar gibt es im menü auf russisch
ja wir sind russische teigtaschen
ähnlich maultaschen oder ähnlich wie man
zu im türkischen also ich glaube die
gibt es auch echt in allen nationen und
in allen ländern überall ein bisschen
anders gehört und anders geformt vor
allem unterschätzter variant höher
ja das ist richtig cool auf schmeckt
sehr lecker man kann sie auf vorrat
einfrieren nicht zeit mich jetzt erst
einmal wie man den leckeren teig
herstellen
für den tag brauche ich 500 gramm mehl
zwei eiern etwa 200 bis 250 milliliter
wasser und etwas morath natürlich salz
drin ein halber teelöffel jetzt nehme
ich zuerst das mehl ihr könnt den teig
natürlich mit der hand kneten oder mit
der küchenmaschine natürlich ein
bisschen einfach auf dann die zwei eier
dazu und je nachdem wie groß die eier
sind brauchte jetzt 200 bis 250
milliliter wasser so dass einfach ein
schöner geschmeidiger teig entsteht da
noch etwas salz reiben
ich gebe erst mal 200 rein und wenn ich
dann noch braucht kommt noch bissl was
dazu
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich einen schönen
geschmeidigen teig da auch nicht so hart
ist und nicht zu weich und den gebe ich
jetzt in eine schüssel rhein kann den
abdecken und dann führt von halbe stunde
ruhen lassen
[Musik]
für die füllung nehme ich 500 fleisch
vom rind 30 milliliter sahne eine
knoblauchzehe und eine zwiebel die habe
ich bereits gewürfelt einen teelöffel
salz und etwas pfeffer für die füllung
nehme ich jetzt das hackfleisch
da kommt die sahne mit dazu das muss
nicht sein das ist echt nur so ein paar
dem man dazu machen kann
dadurch wird nämlich in dissen luftiger
dann klebe und knoblauch angefüllt und
natürlich seien zum treffer
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die pelmeni schon füllen
und zwar nehme ich jetzt in teig und
entweder holte den jetzt hier auf einer
matte oder auf eure arbeitsfläche aus
oder ihr nehmt nudel walzen
also ich mach einmal so und einmal mit
der nudel walze weil es einfach regiert
[Musik]
jetzt nehmt ihr euch einen ausrutscher
oder ein glas zum beispiel und könnt
kreise ausstechen und haben jetzt etwa 5
cm im durchmesser
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier ein bisschen füllung
rein die können ja einfach mit den
fingern verteilen sind 15 wie bei den
typischen mantel ein bisschen größer die
türkische mantel die sind echt ziemlich
klein
und wer ist der teig nicht klebt dann
einfach mit den fingern so ein bisschen
die ränder mit wasser befeuchten und
[Musik]
jetzt nehmen wir den kreis in die hand
und klebt ihn zu einem halbmond zusammen
und da ist immer sehr praktisch wenn
außenrum gewählt ist und innen drin
nicht und falls es doch nicht klebt
einfach mit ein bisschen wasser
befeuchten und jetzt die beiden spitzen
verbinden und zwar so und dann habt ihr
diese kleine teigtaschen
[Musik]
die per mini können jetzt gekocht werden
entweder in salzwasser oder ihr nehmt
direkt etwas früher und ein lorbeerblatt
zum beispiel
[Musik]
nach dem kochen werten sind dann
typischerweise entweder mit essig oder
auch mit sauerrahm angerichtet
[Musik]
also war zuschauer haben sich russische
freunde ja unsere kinder schauen
mögliches fernseh macher der berg ist
auch nur kurz zu und wo du sollst nicht
aufessen du solltest mal probieren weil
ich will auch gleich probieren und die
kinder kommen gleich also ich hab das
jetzt abgekocht in etwas gemüsebrühe oma
kann auch die mini ungekocht einfriert
warmwasser auf vorrat und wir haben sie
noch ein bisschen in butter geschwenkt
natürlich auch super lecker dann kleben
sie nicht und man hat noch ein bisschen
weg geschmack und ich finde es mit
sauerrahm salleck aber es gibt auch die
variante mit essig und dann haben unsere
zuschauer und freunde gesagt zuerst mit
ketchup und mit essen versorgt und
wirtschaftlichste was du musst immer
neuen witz aus denkt aber auch mit den
100 werken ist schon auch bestimmte dort
alle heben die hand von lecker.de und
hat vor allem die schön bissig lass dir
nur so lange kochen bis sie an der
oberfläche schwimmen liebe liebe
türkischen mitbürger mekka schmack als
mantra irgendjemand aus oder schmeckt
man aufarbeiten geschmack vom band
zukunft ist komplett tomatenmark auf
jeden fall den knoblauch dann nach der
wanderung aber schwierig manche müssen
wir mal auf dem kanal machen jedenfalls
könnt ihr das rezept gerne nachmachen
ich bin immer ganz cool gleich fünf kilo
zubereiten einfrieren und dann hat man
weg nicht immer was auf vorrat geht
natürlich nur wenn man groß ins
gefrierfach hat ja eigentlich immer
alles penibel mit zwei über ja machen
manche aber unterschiede nicht vergessen
dass mit glücklichen finder gemacht
vertraglich gebunden wenn du arme
schweine dann musste er macht alles klar
also falls ihr das rezept nach machen
wollt auf meinem blog stets nochmals
alles - blog.de und ich wünsche euch
viel spaß dabei und bis zum nächsten
wagen nicht auf weißen stocks doch nicht
mal rein
[Musik]